[Music]
now i have to be honest clam is one of
my favorite shellfish to cook with
delicious versatile
and they're perfect over pasta or even
toast
or maybe on their own so today i'm going
to show you how to make a delicious clam
dish for a dinner party that you can be
cooked in 10 minutes
right
oscar pan down pan down beautiful little
neck clams the secret behind these is
wash them under cold running water gets
rid of the sort of grain sometimes a bit
sand little bit clay in there but
honestly the cleaner the clam
the more delicious it is
fresh parsley a little bit of tapenade
shallots capers look at these beans a
little bit of a spanish flair going
through these beans they're canned
they've been rinsed drizzled with olive
oil salt pepper chili flakes salt pepper
fresh lemon and
this baby here
sherry vinegar right let's have 10
minutes on the clock and i mean 10
minutes
don't you dare be a shellfish bastard
right pan nice and hot
get that smoking okay i want to flavor
these clams
with a little bit of
garlic
i said a bit of a spanish flake out here
garlic in
okay
salt in lightly
olive oil in lightly beautiful toast
that garlic
toast toast toast
now
once that garlic starts taking color we
want the lid okay
when we compact the lid on top of the
pan it
makes those clams burst open with flavor
here we go clams in
in quickly with the lid
give that a good shake you're starting
to toast those shells okay
that garlic is bursting full of flavor
no sherry vinegar in yet let this steam
keep that heat in there
meanwhile
take your beautiful
focaccia okay
and i'm gonna go sort of sideways nice
and sort of chunky
thick delicious
slices from there
literally
slightly drizzled olive oil
okay salt
pepper
and just rub all that together
okay
get it in there onto the grill
now we want some flavor on that bread
okay
really important
okay
garlic is toasted clams are bursting
open up that lid get some heat in there
a little bit of chili flake in
and then this is where the magic starts
now okay
in lift
in with your cherry
keep that heat in there okay think of
the flavor think of the profile now with
that sherry and
please oscar
pan down beautifully because look inside
there
are those amazing clams i'm gonna lift
that lid
you and i are going to have the most
fragrant facial in history ready
beautiful
back on
when the clams are that small
the quicker you cook them the juicy they
are you don't cook these things for six
seven minutes at a time they're gonna go
really rubbery
now the bread
push that down get some char on there
okay if it's not working just hit it
with a touch more olive oil and that
will get it smoking and charring take
the back of the spoon and push that in i
want flavor on that bread
over
nice
over
nice beautiful
again push it down
now
as that's starting
to toast i want that really nice crispy
sort of crunchy flavored crouton
right gas back down
look at this
oh the smell of that in with the beans
in with the beans just let those beans
sit there
but
take the lemon
and you zest that lemon back over and
i'm doing now is steaming those clams
those beans are going to sort of hit the
shelves
inside
and then literally
from there
i've got my fresh parsley
i'm going to chop it fine just chop it
once that's gonna make it sort of
permeate those clams and think of the
flavor in there
and then finally a little
olive oil over and then all you do now
let's get that lemon
i've got my zest off there now i want
the juice
okay
squeeze that in there
squeeze and look
from there
gas goes off turn the gas off
lid goes back on
and just let it sit there okay now
look at that bread
the bread
is delicious crispy both sides
how do we elevate that focaccia how do
we take this rich dense bread
up into a different level
i've got a really nice tapenade
this tapenade is basically a nice
black olive puree okay and it's done
with olives and anchovies and you just
spread that on that side
the crispier side on back of the spoon
and it's so rustic and charming it is
delicious on
and that nice freshness from that olive
paste is beautiful
now
lighten the load a little bit okay
i've got a sort of
beautiful shallot
i'm going to slice these down into nice
little rings
okay
from there open these up
and just literally
push your fingers through time please
and this is where these clams elevate
they sort of go up
a different level look
i've got the shallot rings which gives a
nice sort of light
flavour
take my
capers squeeze out that juice and
sprinkle them over there
mmm tapenade so good
fresh parsley
chop the parsley
beautiful
in
and all you do now is literally get your
olive oil
in
and your fresh lemon juice
no salt think about what's in there
and just mix that up
and this gives a really nice sort of
vibrant
sort of texture and a crunch
to the toast and look you just sit that
up it's amazing how
a slice of focaccia can look so good
with some
shallots capers and parsley
so good
on top
and then literally
generously hit that on there the
saltiness from that beautiful
incredible
black olive puree and that nice toasted
focaccia bread with those wonderful char
marks
and now look
come
closer look at that
that is beautiful
oh a little taste of the juice
oh man that sherry this fragrant it's a
fortified wine i want to get it a little
bit richer and then from there
generously
you hit the table
oh
oh boy
and then finally
one
two
three
and then
honestly
it's fit for a king a beautiful platter
of clams beans and the most amazing
focaccia bread you glorious shellfish
bastard
i mean that smells good
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsey intent if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down
now don't forget to pick up ramsay and
10 cookbook inspired by this series and
trust me you're gonna come out a much
better chef and if you like this video
don't forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel for more good luck